sie singen von der roten blume simon
router der magische fähigkeiten
zugeschrieben werden in ihrer heimat der
ukraine ist das ein populärer folksong
wir sind in der aula des lyzeums nummer
eins in warschau
780 schüler hatten sie vor dem krieg
jetzt sind es 50 mio innerhalb von tagen
haben sie alle den platz an der schule
bekommen
auf mariana ist aus der ukraine geflohen
unterstützt jetzt das kollegium
seit mitte märz arbeitet sie als
sprachassistentin von der schule
hier haben wir so ein patient wieder
passieren hier haben
sie erlebt ihr die nachrichten dass eure
stadt jacke will
wer also da sind viele verwandten
geblieben und das einfach mit dieser
ganze information schwer die schüler
sind 15 16 jahre alt und müssen eine
neue sprache lernen einfach ist das
nicht auf ein polnischer ukrainische
verband sind dazu kommt noch der ganz
normale unterricht auf polnisch dabei
helfen ihnen sprachassistenten wie
mariana und ihre kollegin katja
also für mich ist es sehr wichtig weil
ich viele auf das nicht nur ganze welt
für uns was macht auch wir selbst machen
was wir selbst können was machen und wir
können diese kinder auch helfen das ist
wichtig dass ich kann etwas für diese
kinder tun es liebe die ukraine steht
auf dem schild im eingangsbereich der
schule
der direktor erklärt mir dass sie alle
versuchen zu helfen es gibt frühstück
und mittagessen kleider und sachspenden
die eltern der polnischen schüler
organisieren fiel aber der krieg ist
immer präsent
wir fragen sie nicht was sie gesehen und
erlebt haben wir warten bis sie selbst
bereit sind darüber zu sprechen
aber bei dem lauten knall einer
zuschlagenden tür wurde eines der
mädchen ist
dann gab es plötzlich an einer stelle im
unterricht ein summen das geräusch
es stellte sich heraus dass einer der
jungen eine sms bekommen dass eine
schule gerade bombardiert worden war
ab diesem zeitpunkt zwar kein unterricht
mehr möglich
ich weiß nicht wie wir es geschafft
hätten diese kinder zu unterstützen und
uns um sie zu kümmern
wenn es nicht marianna und katja gegeben
sie verstehen nicht nur ihre sprache sie
verstehen ihre situation
sie verstehen ihre angst
st
[Musik]
am ostbahnhof in warschau kommen die
züge aus kiew an 20 stunden fahrt liegen
hinter den menschen es ist eine fahrt
raus aus dem krieg
wie ist denn die situation in kiel
die situation ist kritisch aber in kiew
geht es noch einigermaßen
mario leidet sehr aktiv oder verwehrt
sich gut das ist eine stadt voller
helden alle städte sind helden städte
mutter hat sehr gelitten viele frauen
haben sehr gelitten unter diesen
verschissen sie wurden geschändet und
vergewaltigt
wie heißt du weg wie alt bist du ich bin
szene
und
die alten
warum seid ihr hier her gekommen
wir wollen hier sein solange dort krieg
ist wir fliegen anders kann man das
nennen wir lassen unser zuhause zurück
hoffentlich nur vorübergehend
in warschau sind die bahnhöfe voll mit
geflüchteten wo mit vielen freiwilligen
helfern die erklären organisieren
es gibt gratis sim karten fürs handy die
zugtickets für eine weiterfahrt sind für
alle ukraine kostenlos wer will kann
auch weiterfliegen
diejenigen die in polen bleiben können
sofort eine polnische personalnummer
beantragen auch das geht unbürokratisch
und schnell
ich habe ein konto eröffnet und ich
erhalte kindergeld für meine
enkeltochter als ihre aufsichtsperson
es gibt ferner haben sie etwas
lernen warschauer brücke ich werde nach
hause zurückkommen nach dem krieg
ich möchte nach hause
entschuldigung
warschau hat 1,8 millionen einwohner
hunderttausende ukrainer sind
dazugekommen
die stadt hat das wenig verändert sagen
uns viele solidarität mit der ukraine
hier ist das eine selbstverständlichkeit
erklärt mir der bürgermeister roger
scopes die von der wirtschaftsliberalen
bürgerplattform was sind die größten
herausforderungen für ihre stadt
zunächst mal haben wir 300.000 ukraine
willkommen geheißen die meisten sind
privat untergebracht einige sind bei
freunden andere bei familienangehörigen
und wieder andere bei totalem fremd wenn
leute kommen glauben sie manchmal gar
nicht das wirklich so viele hier in
warschau sind weil es keine großen
empfangszentren gibt keine zelte in den
parks einfach nur menschen die ukraine
sind bei uns
die flüchtlinge jetzt werden ganz anders
behandelt als die die über bildungs
kamen
ja das ist es vor ein paar monaten hat
die pis regierung beschlossen eine mauer
zu bauen und natürlich muss man sagen
dass die unruhen von putin und
lukaschenko angezettelt wurden die leute
dahin geschickt haben und ihnen gesagt
haben das eine bessere zukunft in polen
auf sie wartet die regierung hat harte
maßnahmen beschlossen politisch
beurteile ich das nicht ich helfe jedem
der hilfe braucht jeder der nach
warschau kommt erhält hilfe egal ob er
über die belarussische oder die
polnische ukrainische grenze kommt
ich fahre selbst an die polnische
russische grenze wenn mir vor ort ein
bild von der lage machen
am checkpoint ist schluss der polnische
staat ist weder journalisten noch
hilfsorganisationen in eine sperrzone
entlang der grenze
diese bilder stammen vom polnischen
grenzschutz vor gut vier monaten hat
holen damit begonnen einen hohen zaun zu
bauen immer wieder hatten die bilder
russen migranten meist aus syrien oder
dem irak über die grenze gedrängt
menschenrechtsorganisationen kritisieren
aber auch polen dafür dass sie die
menschen zurück schicken pusch becks
nennt man das viele stranden im
niemandsland
die gräber auf einem friedhof unweit
dieser zone sind zeugnis für das drama
dass ich immer noch hier abspielt
flüchtlinge gestorben und in den
polnischen wäldern
ein paar kilometer weiter in michael wo
treffe ich die stadtverordnete marion
gerade hat die ukraine bei sich
aufgenommen erzählt sie mir aber seit
monaten kümmert sie sich auch um die
flüchtlinge die über die belarussische
grenze kommen immer gibt dem
schöpfergott ich kann einfach nicht
akzeptieren dass es dieselben menschen
sind die vor krieg fliehen und die
anders behandelt werden unsere grenzer
tragen die einen kinder auf dem arm und
zwingen hier die anderen kinder zurück
über die grenze
die einen bleiben unter großartigen
bedingungen weil sie essen wasser und
unterkunft bekommen und die anderen
sitzen mit ihrem kleinen kindern im wald
das ist einfach unerträglich
dass nicht wie erklären sie sich die
unterschiedliche behandlung ab es ist
ein befehl dass die unterschrift unseres
präsidenten das push becks legal sind um
diese leute wieder hinter den zaun zu
befördern
in warschau hat mariana das freundliche
polen erlebt hatte hilfe bekommen von
ewa die hat er über arbeitskollegen von
ihr und ihren kindern gehört und ihnen
spontan eine wohnung zur verfügung
gestellt kostenlos sieben wochen ist das
her inzwischen sind die beiden frauen
freundinnen und ich wünsche ihnen das
ende des krieges und dass sie zu ihren
familien zurückkehren
aber wir haben uns schon so aneinander
gewöhnt dass ich mir nicht vorstellen
kann dass sie jemals zurückgehen wir
besuchen uns ja wir werden uns
gegenseitig besuchen als er gekommen ist
haben wir uns gleich sehr gerne gehabt
wir haben uns direkt umarmt und lieb
gewonnen
ich besuche marian in ihrer wohnung am
stadtrand von warschau zwei tage nach
kriegsausbruch ist die ausländer
geflohen mit ihren drei kindern und zwei
patenkindern diamant ist in der ukraine
geblieben das ist das schwierigste für
die kinder wir sprechen darüber aber ich
versuche auch die kinder aber
ich versuche auch nicht die kinder sagen
dass die arm sind dass sonae ich sage
dass die haben in dieser situation so
ein chance
das land zu lernen neue sprache zu
lernen und hauptsache neue leute
kennenzulernen
so ist das ganze als bereicherung zu
erklären dass man ja
das ist so dass ich
versuche nicht etwas schlechtes zu
finden weil es gibt so soviel jetzt
schlecht dass
gemeinsam am tisch sitzen auch wenn es
eng ist in der kleinen zweizimmerwohnung
mariana findet das wichtig gerade für
die kinder
die familie will unbedingt zurück nach
lemberg in warschau geht sie in die
griechisch-katholische ukrainische
kirche um die vertraute sprache die
gesänge zu hören
[Musik]
für mein land wünsche ich frieden
und auch dass wir
ziemlich schnell das alles aufbauen und
noch viel viel
viel
besser als vorher war
frieden für die ukraine das ist die
hoffnung die ihr und ihren kindern halt
gibt
[Musik]